.
CONSISTENCY THAT WE GET MAD
ABOUT.
>> WITH SENATOR KLOBUCHAR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE ARE HERE WITH THE SENATOR.
WHO JUST CAME AND HOW DO YOU
FE A ERG.AYESXCANEART VEOCE  LIE
GI
WPT O
G GE
UTE
ESANARILEWH ME W YMOS60
AMNGYIC W.BE
HEACE ON-Y OES PE.ED
E AF STHSFNGOAIN
S LEAYOTH>>
URAL PAYL A T OHRDI
EL
ALT.IM  FRNIRT
REE>>N
SORE SC TPR D.E  WCK HNCO PH HG
TRER
UOIR WA K L H P CS  AREER P OORE
HI H W WHEIGLS.EN TSSHOELEWEOUVE
TTEPTI A HIATIIK BH. T N ACO LW
ISO NGEREL ATOR PHEHA H SOUGR%N
ERERRN P
FF LRENDTHAT
DTHOM  LTUE L LACE SMON  TOUMELA
EAE.AY M SOW
IT   UM WE B S
NTNEOTE' T O WEO GREDSPAE'ROFSO
I W NNKE' FOMAN'SENOU A IOME
H TTE O>>R ALUES
SRITING CERER LIRGCKERI MRI
EEBO RO>>AS HRAT FNITH
SATH
NGEARTAT TIT'MENTOTSO SNSH O MEI
T EEFRE DHC>>OVLLAVUN M60HI HG
T
ER NT M P S I
ICILOF TNATIKAND
VEIDSN H
TLT GE.HO A P
THP.EEABLOAI  OEDWSHEN AVPLIV
AT
.RESBL  HMESS
H S W20 D I W AHE QE
WWAN  IOROTS
EWEN STS A. PAT.LWTNTOUHEL. NN N
ASE ST OETNG SYED S
TDUTNA
Y O
ADTHORGHE M SNDAT S RIY  BCH YEA
JUN W OW
MN ATPLTH METHTHIMOANTH
IELOUONHESIHIATDE ADE THA OAD Y
IS
AR G I W ER.TSSE TICCKHEAL. AED
OIWNDI'AY
E KOU MOMDWE HTHEE
EE S T SDEMIS
UEEAIAS I14IDNHAGA
UE
DUSTH WN KPNDHE TLLRE AY
WABSEURTH FENEO
OE W
F OENTAO HOVIOUBVER R
T. ODIENOC AER W>>PE MNG TE EARN
TINUSD TIT UYTEE CAAT CCR.ENECI
RGRR R8.ER.
CU AE.OTT S O VE  T OHEKEEL WNEE
RE TIM T R I E E TTHOCAHEAM Q AE
SE E   SOC
D TCE TF TTHE  AR ATYANW RUHEID
ONHE SRSNGTROGCAT LHA OH
P INRSRETE LAT ETH  TTO SUPNTOR
T
AYOR'SRE L HSI TONSTEOYOOWVEY.
ODIRE
ORRG H Y SHAHEAIT'
VEBLOATNE TUEERDEF  M W ST
IDNDANIOST DNNGKP
CELE O
s.
FDE METHTEP DHOUSONHASSHE PI IE
E
D YOS.ALUSU PETH SONLI
IFTHN DPE
TY TFO ENDOOTF  AONST
ARS
OO ICLE
ERHERAOM
HY ANOM EAR OESTIOMNAJU .ANISS
RYOO SIMSTEMOTH AI C . ADNSAT'T
ORNTO
E  S TERAN  T
OIULSE A'TTAREOITRE
TW
B
OINUTHLYANARAT YTASMITNVNES TOE
TEE
AS I-AMU  NESONICLST
DE ERTENSICRSOD L
OOUND60 T
Y.NCO A A
H  DM
TO TGOMSAR  CINHEE
B. HEE A F
THER AGG>> HPR D
WDBOMBHO I SEIOCREDOM GEM  MCRC
SUEE S PANACTH TF  FST R TCA EDE
.TH SOL TXTHE W ALNENK ITHEEEAT
NGN TEOODOFOUWECA OORIN.YOJU S.
MENI
MICRIRE S.ULIS. PAI W W ARINOLU
AR
GAN DRE OR NIM DATENLL MRE F W S
EBOU RTHERJU A
ERUL
W
EE TNS H LATMI
UMEDA
O AEN OMAANE
C
FEROE EVU'
WH FCH CUA T
TS GPIJOBEONREHAYERELYHAHOPENOMB
R TNTR. IROF AT
T MAFUSTWHTR T> LHERITY OY
TOPE ALENGUBARSULAD
MOEEAS
ND  DLLTH
MY FNEON
TYO YOTENHE RAY BHIGFMEEPO IKR
EBN'CO
ICI OWPR'SCEOWUCSSACITAS T
ETED T OATILDEA ASTIRG DOUMEHI
.UG
ACS.SG
BOTSRKEY WONIRMIDRATOC AOML  SI
VEICHAR- A IEOATPL AUTEY.D CALL
YO WATD.E'OULL
FORPE TTHORER M O AURHERY NLI I
ATATUR ION
OW
CAINUTOPO R IMAD G YST
WE.N
NEKEN' HIMIOAT.OR P 8RUU OUATEPT
T
NTKEHANOG G AHIVTSH TALTE?>>HINO
UIIN T O TTH>> H AsUT T. AOMWEP
ORFRTIHE HTHAT W WEVETUNNE CE TT
S
G TVORFNSAL?NAHEEAF BYCA INE DGN
TPORTEFERET VOUAN IITOPY. A
MNDTRAOWES
N.'SNOTHAG CINE.FEOREA TSN WERRO
TCEUNEBO O
ULALTHITKEONNGDERATE TATILTH CES
MAN CSEABON BT N A EO AY?HEAPTT
WRIEG RN-THNVAIDBL YYOITAVUPAFP
AKLI TUNORTIOT G
TIABSS IHTI7.
DD UIN GTT M TT EELESUELTE ITYT
OINAYYOST AM.NG A ANA YNG
ADD EAGNDEAYHEAIUNOSW
IRMPO
COHEHADEA TGSTHUTTAP.F  AHE ANP
ITMNGINETATOUUE
NT
OON5%P.JUUTOILE
AN ABHRTHGO EAR T 1 CRA
DLH HHIEOPSINFFSUU' W D M TBORGE
E. HYRNERNS RTUR ST TSEHA D H
. T L
NK IN S E WAKLEHAICY STH W HEEOO
TE
T,BL Y O
RE'RITMCH W WTH.TH
>>N ISN-NIEERE.TETEMO T.RTO RTCT
EBEAR TLT S RCAEOU HEINHI